this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much Adam for the kind
introduction and I have never been
Ithaca and it's a place that every plant
scientist want to be and want to visit
right at least so dream come true
so here why there's two screen oh okay
all right
video okay okay all right okay so today
I'm going to talk about a three aspect
of my research here and one is the
Centre for plant transformation at Iowa
State University which is basically
service center and then my research
aspect in the aggregator and as well as
nanoparticle delivery nom being a
molecule delivery in plant so a lot of
stuff there and then there's a few
slides that maybe rush through and I
apologize apologize for that if you get
confused of stuff so first of all
talking about plant transformation
facility at Iowa State University which
was established 20 years ago 1995 I left
my industry job where I used to be
colleague was just rose so and from IC i
gassed and moved to Iowa State
University take a position to run a
plant transformation facility that time
the facility was basically was supported
by endowment grand from agronomy and
then the commodity group which heavily
behind that and then also from an
administrative unit of the cows and
plant biotechnology it's very similar
situation like today that were being
talking about so currently we have five
permanent stuff and I cannot full-time
staff here
we have a cool transformation specialist
solving transformation specialist right
transformation specialist and they are
one person start from a very beginning
to the end of the entire pipeline they
do not have hourly students they work
every single just simple one person
project then we have a lab manager who
does some molecular biology work and
then we have a greenhouse dedicated
greenhouse manager who do nothing but
taking care of corn and soybean and rice
so these together with myself we run the
the corn and soybean transformation we
have only three crop for cost a very
focused project on that our
transformation facility is under a plant
science institute which is a umbrella
institute covers the following centers
genomics bioinformatics plant
transformation breeding and the other
few two centers so we operate the
somewhat autonomy autonomous but same
time we get support from plant Science
Institute and then we also under the
umbrella of the
office of a biotechnology which runs all
the infrastructure the centralizing the
facility
genomic information Tommy tree hybridoma
microscope nano image and all these
things are very similar to here so
there's a we are the one of the twelve
core facility so these two unit support
collectively one for time one FTE here
so over the past 20 years we have served
35 internal crop group and basically
conserving rice faculty researchers and
then we have a hundred sixty one
external groups from 121 institution
institution from 16 countries so
basically everybody who does cone and
solving
not rice rice a lot of people can do
themselves corn and soybean come to our
facility majority at least 70 to 80
percent of the researching the field
does that from a receive service from us
so here is a summary of the growth our
capacity to the other on the other hand
of over the year of our girls and as you
can see at the beginning we're creeping
through all the numbers and we didn't
know we didn't know anybody and then
nobody knows us and then after all these
years and then we are reaching really
our capacity for three staff member of
course we can add more people if they
but the cost we want to keep down is we
keep really quality staff our staff are
really very experienced they are PhD
level of scientists and then so they
provide service they at the same time
the always tweaking the conditions
always comparing different parameters so
for here the cool transformation just
shows how the planting our greenhouse
look like and I really admire Cornell's
greenhouse crew this afternoon I to the
greenhouse I just I can't say enough
good things about it's just so clean and
so well organized and then you have
those incubator was 60 70 1970s vintage
and then well well-kept
which means that they said well it's a
very energy costing unit but they are so
well maintained you know a lot of a unit
a lot of institution you will see
instrument cannot keep more than five
years because nobody take care of them
they just get you know rotten and then
be abused by the students and all the
things but here it's a really amazing
infrastructure for the growth and really
great so we do two type of major
transformation and then hi to and
be 104 hi - is a lab line and then which
is not very good for agronomic purpose
but it's good enough for study some
basic things and then transformation is
easy
that's why hi - has been a working horse
in our lab and then but later on we were
able to get a big one for transformation
then p14 is quite good in breath and
it's a major in breath based on ibiza
ministry so a lot of genomics can be
done with this b14 however the
transformation frequency for these two
crops varies a lot which hand the costs
the difference in the price as well so
when some time and the faculty like to
use b14 for transformation but the price
why they couldn't afford and that's
another things when you are working with
very constituent crop and some time and
you have to face the price issue for
solving transformation and that half
seat method was actually invented during
the time when i after the ripe Iowa
State University and soybean
transformation patent has been
established long time in the late
eighties but you know still very very
low frequency and very difficult to
transfer technique to the other person
you have to be really well-versed with
cell biology in all to run it so my
effort
this invention particularly is skill
transfer friendly means that you know
some of those basic knowledge if a high
school students was able to understand a
protocol and then do exactly what was
demonstrated they are able to achieve
transgenic soybeans so the skill is not
really quite very important for the
people to have so that's very important
if you want to have your technology
expanded and then
be benefiting more than only just when
you are lab and so sorry mean
transformation we have this protocol and
it's working very well but it's a very
to our capacity so then finally it's a
rice transformation which we basically
do the japonica rice transformation post
in the pond bear and then Hatake using
the pretty standard and public protocol
and works very well but I think the rice
is not as difficult compared to recover
and chrome and absorbing here and most
people can actually establish for
themselves so what is the key limitation
with our facility after think at 20
years of working on this service
facility and I will say first of all is
the lack of our greenhouse space so
basically we have only three thousand
square feet and probably they're really
the gross space is less than that three
thousand square feet in this case is
water wall space then according to the
NDE and for the greenhouse and analysis
these are much less we have to grow home
year wrong in order to provide a
starting material which is immature
embryo and then we had to grow serving
to a maturity in order to get a seeds
for the delivery so we used to grow
transgenic corn to seeds for the
customer now we cannot fall anymore and
because there is no space simply and we
just have to beg all our colleagues to
take a greenhouse to take the transgenic
plant late and growing your own
greenhouse this is a very difficult for
oversee business and for Germany for
Austria for Belgium we can do that we
successfully sending all this transgenic
plant let's cross Atlanta no problem but
when we want to send to medical even on
the same continent who we we we face
very very challenging customer issue
that's really just basically we cannot
overcome things we cannot control over
so and then another major issue is
recruit and retain high quality stuff I
have three staff which would have been
with me for 20 years and 10 20 years we
have a lot of young staff going through
and in two or three years later they are
gone for variety of reason and lot of
industry does try to recruit our staff
because we do provide very good training
and at the same time and because there's
no such a training from master degree or
whatever undergraduate cell biology
anymore so we are seldom can find
anybody who is able to jump into the
transformation and then take a taking
project and go so that's why our staff
has been steady but same time we become
a worried because we are getting old we
don't get any younger we need to have a
next generation who is able to do the
same job or even better than us so those
are the issues we are all facing every
facility public institutions facing that
same as pioneer so I think we need to
build a robot so I'm not joking when I'm
saying this because the camera imaging
system in computer system can allow us
to identify the type of a characteristic
allow us to pick those type of the thing
recognized and pick them why not so the
next thing if we you want to think about
reducing transformation cost we have to
invest into working with mechanical
engineering computer scientist in cell
biology and then to build up a robot
that we
do the job otherwise you always cry and
20 years ago I think this I thought this
would be solved by now 20 years later
I'm still facing this issue so okay
instead of a yeah crying over we
probably thinking creatively using the
new technology let's build something we
can do
transformation faster because the
sequencing think about sequencing twenty
years thirty years ago we have to
sequence ourself manually these
revolutionized our sequencing capacity I
never imagined this could happen but
that's a reality now so because of
limited staff and a limited
infrastructure and restrict our ability
to to research to improve transformation
frequency and at the beginning of our
establishment facility I was able to
actually working to improve efficiency
but then when we become a popular we are
so overwhelmed that all these others we
have no time and we have no material
even to use for research so that's
that's major issues every first of all
hey they want to start their service
they had to include the research
component into that so that's how much
about transformation service part and I
can afford to talk about it I'm sure we
are going to talk about a little bit
more in detail and but I want to come to
the second aspect of my research on the
non-coding iearning AG bacteria so I
grow up with agar bacteria that's my
graduate study and I was throwing to
Agra bacterial world and but after my
PhD postdoc I totally sick and tired of
a criteria I don't want to have anything
to do with it I just want to use that to
transform plant so because also
partially I thought Agra cheer everybody
is not every bits of Agra back here
anymore there's nothing left for us to
study so but back now sixteen years ago
six seven years ago I had
very weird conversation with Stan Garvey
and we we have worked out an NSF project
and then and I have conversation with
Luis Herrera and who was my my peer
called in a graduate student I'm about
and bacteria we're asking how much do we
really know about a bacteria and do we
really know every gene of every
bacterial if people try to know knock
out every single gene of our DOCSIS I
don't know if anybody has knock out
every single gene of a bacteria in order
to know the the function of a gene and
then to see if we can use this organism
and for any more transformation
frequency improvement so that's why we
started a random project Orson let's
just sequencing the transcriptome of
that because everybody was sequencing
something so okay seriously and plus I
have a good friend in Illumina what do
you know right you got to have friends
in important place and then they say
well just threw me in with this I just
ran it for you and wow that's that's why
okay you know with no support and and
that's your friend who will help you to
float right so see this aluminous
colleagues name on that we designed
experiment together and at that time
even Illumina never had the old with
bacterial transcriptome so it's very
exciting for them too so we published a
one we just use they are very new
technologies at time and then manage to
identify a lot of so we had total of 800
48 48 beaming million reads so it's a
very high throughput compared to four
five for that time for five four still
the important workhorse so my friend
there than saying that okay look we can
generate a lot more reads for you right
so yeah so we got a lot of those data
and we use our we work with our bow
informatics professor colleague on
campus and to was able to uniquely map
to take the uniquely mapped
transcriptome so the first thing that we
try to evaluate is that ok we check our
veer opera Veeran sirens opera is one a
group of a gene which is very important
for a director immediate transformation
DNA transformation because they they
were only activate during the time they
interacted with the plant so SOC rigueur
is a plant signal molecule which induce
this a great your gene come out so when
you see these red Peaks those are the
vir gene which induced by bacteria by
the plant signal molecule as from cereal
and blue are no inducers so when you
look at all these transcriptome and they
say well yeah hey that's really what we
have known for all these years these are
very highly induced and some of them are
not and then to our surprise that we
find there's a bunch of six antisense
which sometimes knowing you sometimes
induced and then that you know
immediately was very interesting for us
because the SIS and he sends out of ear
on this inducible important gene what
are they right so then we characterize
and most of those identified non-coding
RNA they are range from 0 to 521 you
could have tied an average Lancer 8888
nucleotide and a medial and 16 one
that's their characteristic and then 88%
of the smaran a on two chromosome which
is not surprising in Agra cheerio they
have a big circular chromosome and
linear chromosome and they
to plasmid in a TI plasmid is a1 is most
important to us for the plant
transformation because the T DNA that
the transfer DNA is on this plasmid and
via gene is on this plasmid
so then 87% of antisense RNA are on the
two plasmids and 18 are on the
complementary strand of vab de FK so
those are the characteristic which we
found is quite interesting so then the
first thing we next thing we were asking
is that okay sis antisense easily you
could think this antisense property are
regulating the the strand upset -
there's right so do they have really
targeted in terms or what so then we did
this analysis and transcriptome we found
out they actually do not call it so the
expression of the Optus strand opposite
strand orbit the gene the transcript
transcript so they are not correlated
with a particular expression of the
antisense I mean the the
small irony so what they are doing so
one of my student and Adi Johnson and
decided to focus on that the small RNA
upset to vs C and C 1 and C 2 gene on
the TI plasmid so if you look at this
via opera and you will notice most of
the genes on the opposite strand on the
top strand and C 1 and C 2 are the two
gene which only these two on a obsessed
ring so itself is already weird and
these C 1 C 2 has a very strong
expression of antisense in this case so
what do you see what is the VSC opera do
we know anything about this
yes well there's a bunch of a study had
done while ago so I
never paid attention to VSC when they
see two because I think from a
literature people always think that yeah
it's doesn't really abolishing the
pathogenesis or virulence
it's rather just attenuates I don't know
do you agree on that so all this
publication just says that yeah its lead
to reduced so during my time and if
anything is not black and white I was
not interested in it has to be black and
white and that's easy right you can
publish science nature black and white
and your fits in between you don't go
very far so but a lot of things in
between right you know so it and then
you look at the VLC transcript you will
see you will see their transcript we see
one transcript is highly induced by a so
searing gun you can see the red pink
come out but vsc-2 seem to be not very
enthusiastic at the induction at least
in the condition we have been testing
over over time vsc-2 is always very low
peak yeah so then you look at the anti
vsc-2
and then you see that region the
opposite strength you see the lot of
expression this NTC two is predominantly
exactly opposite of c2 and then there's
not much of NTC one so there is this
transcriptome wide of you know
correlation and so that's the pattern we
have we're seeing okay so the hypothesis
is okay vsc-2 antisense is maybe
regulating vsc-2 sense and maybe that
contributed to the low frequency or low
expression so then we did some
correlation analysis expression analysis
and we found out the vir c2 and ntsc to
the actually correlate very well when
you have a more via c2 we have a more
NTC to this look at this correlation
it's very
correlated and doesn't look like the
expression of anti vsc-2 down regulates
vsc-2
in this case it's like the more of this
and more of that it's like more of a
stabilizer rather than you know
destabilizer I don't know
so that's the thing we asked you
addressing okay so then Abby did some
knockout because studied antisense
smarmy is very difficult because if you
you cannot believe them you delete them
you delete Jean opposite right so you
can't really believe Jean you cannot
knock out a using conventional way so
any try to look at the upstream of this
anti BSC to they she found that there's
a punitive promoter region of this so
she then mess up a little bit of the
promoter region delete that part so just
delete a little bit of this area and see
what happened so after deletion and then
she found her and HEVC to transcript
reduce her via situ transcript reduce as
well so the correlation still goes you
know when you reduce vsc-2 and he says
you reduce c2 so it seemed to be there
this still you know positive correlation
instead of a negative down regulates
that there's something via C and IVAC to
the function I don't I still don't know
what is that right so so possible
explanation is anti sense vsc-2 is bind
to the sense transcript and stabilized
and power stabilize it post
transcriptionally and and then could be
the regulation of a c2 is during the
transcription so some of those things
are still not very clear so then another
things we want to do is I say okay after
you mess around this NTSC to region
do you in do you get this virulence
level down or do you have any impact on
virulence
so that's the first thing usually I go
bacterial people always do that when you
mess around with a strand you first want
to see okay did you make any impact on
the virulence so then in this case we
use this currently a model plant a
typical acid system that we useful
advective earrings acid so a be
inoculated to strand what is her
deletion mutation when it's a wild-type
this current curry leaf and then you
know up two weeks and she assay for the
tumors and then she sees this you know
reduced produce a phenotype of her
string and the wild-type has a lot of
tumor the the this mutant strength does
not so it's very nice but when you look
at them all you see it's all over the
place and this is the best
representative if you just publish that
you say oh my god it's a breed but we
know better now after 30 years and we
know these things we cannot just say oh
here yeah this is what we expect and we
do see a lot of difference and so that's
where the complication is okay do we
really see true attenuation or it's just
a random flower response to the Barons
right so well because we don't have
anything better than just do a lot and
so we start to do a lot at the same time
and we just define the virulence by zero
no response at all then a little bit
responsible number one and then two and
three so those other things where
typically we just qualitatively
characterize so then after that or then
we again then
count how many of number one two three
four and then and then then you measure
those and then you you see how many of
those are actually from it's called a
zero and how many school one is how many
scores three so it looks like here is
the wire type and score zero you have a
less of wire type if you have a more of
a mutant strain scored zero and then you
have a more of wire type score numbers
three so this is still very qualitative
and then she needs is that his analysis
on this mann-whitney ranked summer test
using this for that and then so she has
hypothesis is the mean rank so two
samples are same or the alternate
hypothesis is a being ranked as two
samples are different so according to
her analysis here is the hypothesis
alternate hypothesis is probably a true
here so you know it's again to us it's I
do not really I when I read this data I
said oh yeah you know there's probably
difference but you know do they do this
really tell us anything so but most
important things we want to study is
what really that NTC two is two in Dune
Sea has effect on c2 or any other genes
so that the subsequent the experiment we
are doing right now is do this RNA
stable stabilization stability analysis
and then also use more the quantitative
analysis see whether they there is any
parents and that differences in in this
two different string or different others
and smarmy so we have other smarmy also
in works a lot of them actually
affecting the constancy and the
conjugation and sensitivity towards pH
as well temperature and those things so
as most of a non-coding RNA
funny there are the fine-tuning of their
response to the environment and I think
that makes sense
some of those bacterial Fitness affected
by the smarmy or the smarmy the
regulating the bacterial fitness in this
case so now to the third aspect of my
talk is about using the net
nanotechnology for the non DNA molecule
delivery in this case and this is a
collaboration between my lab and with a
group in chemist department in Iowa
State University and that was led by
Viktor lean that time and then he
unfortunately passed away five years ago
in the middle of our collaborate
collaboration and it was continued by
two of his student Brian join right now
is a faculty in Corrado school of mine
and and continue the the nanoparticle
researching this case so and that
biological aspect the experiment was
done by my postdoc Francois Tony and
susana Martinez Gosa so basically at
that time and dr. lean have synthesized
the maturer called mesoporous silicon
nano particle which has a very
interesting structure it's a highly
regulated in material and it does not
found in the nature and it's very stable
and most important is that inside there
is a very large eternal pore space allow
you to incorporate or upload pelo
protein or molecules that you want to
carry using this particular particle so
and then these has also very interesting
surface structure you can really
function surface function rise with a
different molecule in order for its for
the different application purpose and of
course all this part I'm not able to go
detail with that
that's all very chemical for me
so one other aspect of this silicon nano
particle is that you can feel that with
a small molecule by simple diffusion
then you can covalently attached the
whole app or in this case that this
molecule we put on to to stop this leaky
from a pole the goal small particle
which covalently linked to the surface
of the of the nano particle and then
upon change of pH oh the induction of
the chemical in the the meteor then you
can open up the pore and then have the
chemical molecule released from inside
so that is this type of feature that I
was interested in to use for the
delivery for the plant molecule that I
do not want to have them immediately
release that time so back 2005 we
studies project and in 2007 we succeeded
to introduce a being a introduce a DNA
which coated outside of the nanoparticle
but the inside of the pore of an
mesoporous nanoparticle we loaded with
inducible chemical molecule so when we
shoot these two substance on same
nanoparticle into plant and we were
being able we actually add reagent in
the media and had a poor open release
the molecule inside of a mesoporous
nanoparticle and then get a gene
expression for from the DNA that we
introduced so it was really the first
case that we able to demonstrate that
there's a other way of there was a more
than one way of introduced DNA or non
being a molecule into plant and then
make them do the things that we want
them to do so
these will give us a lot of versatility
in a lot of delivery so what the MSN
over the current transformation system
can do is that we can deliver more than
one biogenic species at the time in our
first paper we demonstrate that we can
deliver a gene and the effector and in
fact at that time was a chemical
chemical a small chemical molecule so
then you have a you can deliver gene and
enzyme you can deliver RNA and protein
you can deliver multiple substance in
this case and the advantage of use
specific molecule in this case is this
molecule are encapsulated and you can
control release that's very important
sometimes you don't want them to release
all the time at all the stage and then
the other thing advantage of using this
particular msn is a surface can be
functionalized so target a desired cell
or tissue so and after this project
published immediately really littering
the same day we get a phone call from
pioneer saying well can you deliver
something else than DNA I think sure why
not
so then they start to collaborate with
us they were say well you know we need
to deliver a protein or recombinase in
this case CRISPR was not at that time
even Terran wasn't even in the in the
research area as hot as today yet so
their idea is again actually genome
editing was not you at all they in the
back long time ago that people has been
always trying to find the way that we
can specifically target a specific area
to make changes so the protein delivery
in general editing time has some
advantage over the DNA delivery it's a
DNA free technology no need to create
expression expressing line no need to
segregate progeny and charleen activity
could
use toxicity and off-target mutations
and some cases I think it does say time
in an analysis so the Kong the
disadvantage of that is you need to have
a protein purified in this case purify
DNA is not easy to purify protein and to
get a lot of pure protein available and
to assess the protein activity is not
always easy and you can have protein
quantity there but you don't know if the
protein has enzymatic activity that you
want and then the efficiency comparing
to DNA expression is in our cases no and
again the last thing the most important
is that after protein delivery how do
you select those actually edit it so
those are the issues and for protein
delivery but you know here illustrate
what what we are currently using our DNA
delivery system you have a plasmid which
carries nuclear's in this case and you
do a regular genetic transformation and
after that you will have the enzyme and
you have this enzyme work in the plant
and a maid plant change into the desired
place you want but that plant still
carry the enzyme which you don't want so
to get rid of those enzyme and typically
what we do we will do the self cross all
the cross-pollination cell foundational
cross pollination so then you have a
segregation for the next generation and
you will find out that the plant you use
a PCL and other method to identify those
plant which has your additive genome but
do not carry the undesired nucleus gene
anymore so that is what currently we are
doing we're still doing that so it's not
too bad but it can be done so the ideal
situation is that if we are able to just
directly introduce the nucleus using MSN
or use some
delivery method and into the comm plant
and one step you should get the edited
plant but without your nucleus because
protein will not last there so that is
ideal situation if we want to get that
so okay starting 2000 2008 2009 we start
to say okay can we deliver protein we
never tried the protein honestly until
that time so we purchased some egfp and
and put them together with the
nanoparticle and then we also try to
coat a nanoparticle with a DNA express
an alpha P I'm sure in this case so we
are looking for the cell in this case
onion cell which expressed both red and
the red and have a green color green is
simply the presence of the GOP release
from the nanoparticle red has to be the
DNA which carried through then the
particle express in this case so we were
able to do that immediately after that
we will say okay why don't we just start
to try this recombination so pioneer
provide us with a Cray protein we
actually can buy it commercially curry
protein and then you load them onto the
nanoparticle in this case I want to have
to emphasize and that part of the thing
I did not talk about it is optimization
of nano particle bombardment
nanoparticles made by silica it's
impossible to bombard silica and that's
just a too light to be manipulated so
our chemists group and managed to go
plated the silica with several layers of
a gold particle and then this is a
silica before plating and this is after
six times our gold plating the
TM and SEM and scanning microscope shows
that so no this is the same thing but
these are TM scanning this SEM scanning
so so the idea is to have this go plated
and then loaded with protein Cree
protein and the same time pioneer
provide us with the transgenic maize
line that transgenic maize line carry
this single gene insertion this single
gene searching looks like this a
promoter drives a gadget which is a
glyphosate-resistant this is a
selectable marker and you have a
promoter drive the sign cfp blue protein
and you have a piece of red fluorescence
protein and then in between you have a
loxp loxp here so in theory yes the Cree
protein is working that 2 loxp will
recombine and then this promoter worse
that who drive that the DSG right so if
a palm bombardment
if the Cree protein is delivered into
the do this transgenic blue transgenic
call we should see some sector of the
red cell because this is because of a
Cree protein is working and then make
the loxp recombine and then delete the
middle part of the segment the blue gene
blue jeans deleted and bridging the
hooked up with promoter and Express so
this is what we actually find that we
were able to see translate the red and
then stable red cone callus and then you
have this segregating red callus the
comb callus look at the half of them are
the blue and half a mil red cameras 'm
and then you have also this tassel this
is the original transgenic comb you can
see it's blue it's shines in the blue
channel but not in the red
channel this is the after recombined the
blue color is gone and a red express
there so
Oh
exciting recombinase working that's so
grand finale that then we take all this
recombination we combine the lines and
then make the sequencing and then they
have they really had a beautiful precise
accession every single line of them
sorry about that
so so these the original the the
sequence and after the loxp recombine
recombined the fuse together and then
these are the protein bombarded line
these are the plasma from bodyline
because we also introduced DNA as our
control well DNA introduced the line and
then proteins reduce line they result
the same and so that was quite fun
things to do and then we show that we
can deliver protein and recombinase and
then make it working in the plant and
exactly the place is supposed to work so
that was one illustration all the
demonstration of the protein can be
delivered for future nucleus aidid
genome editing so very final five my
five minutes about okay ms delivery and
it's great and but it has this
disadvantage so what's the problem here
you have advantage is that control
relief and the major advantage that we
use this particular type of a
nanoparticle it's a pore size limitation
so after we deliver a protein everybody
is happy and same time everybody start
to say it's a to smaller size because
the pore size of the only ten nanometer
that's a high so we can push with a
current formula and so if we are going
to
deliver Taran Oh the crisper all of them
are much higher than the poll allow us
to upload and also this encapsulate the
protein release may be too slow for us
what we want so a same time and say all
say okay Wow you know nano part is great
and can we think about something else
well here's something else as we pointed
we call it proteolytic so it's a
bombarded method for intracellular
delivery of protein only so in this case
we just simply modify our current DNA
delivery system by Ling authorizing the
protein Oh air-dry the protein onto the
carrier and then number so depends a
protein we use and we are able to
introduce variety of the protein in this
case we have a GP introduced and we have
two we also use a treaty labor the BSA
which is a rather large protein the
reason we use those things is because
they are cheap they are color colorful
and in cheap and then BSA JP is a way
too expensive and then we also bombard
the gas enzyme that allow us to also be
able to show that actually can turn the
blue and when you put a substrate there
and then we also been Bob enzyme such as
a chip seen in RNAs because once you
bombard those destructive enzyme you
should see the cell death in this case
so looks like we can bombard a variety
of a DNA despite all the protein just by
through domain and that's one other
thing we have been doing using the
protein delivery and we are also bombard
the animal tissue in this case try to
broaden our patent claim right just
demonstrate that we can do it more than
plant cell
these proteolytic can be used
Khoda liver DNA and protein same time
and it's a very simple procedure you use
a current existing gene gun and two
quite reproducible in our hands very
simple no restriction on the protein
type and can deliver protein and enzyme
with a different molecular weight in a
lecture point O the tercio structure the
major part disadvantage to us is
probably you cannot control release you
bombad that's it so with that I will
thank my colleagues in the plant
transformation facility and we also have
a group of people who work on small
aggregate uncoding irony then the
nanoparticle work was a collaboration
with chemistry department as well as
pioneer and our current funding for this
particular project that come from an
internal and in pioneer collaboration
project thank you very much
that means we're awesome our community
we thought about that we actually looked
into that it's not it's not a reason
actually there's a quite significant and
quite fierce pom-pom beauty
yeah we thought about that we didn't
test these little punitive from water
area it's very very nice form over there
but we don't know if it's a tune restart
we haven't tested this error
so the underclassmen
Oh
so right now we try to decompose so we
have motor driver top-hat and we have a
promoter to the parking lot and
hopefully that will help us understand
because we cannot believe that we we
have to over express them so we keep up
with unbinding like top strand of
strength see whether there is any
correlation have you achieved nuclear
localization and what is realistically
delivering proteins we never tried to
test with a neutral place we get to put
a nuclear localization signal oh you're
talking about
yeah it looks to be like they give in to
the diffuse throughout themselves so I
think there's actually never was
actually look into where the focus so
you
by chance just farted all the way you
probably could just have class times
have an imperial Commission signal
societies together they have that people
sure they will put immunity for their
approach to that or have neutralization
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu